this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream and my own nebula original series
more on that later in 2019 a load of
music videos that have been uploaded to
YouTube in the early days of the
platform were remastered YouTube like
the music labels keep the same video IDs
along with all the views and comments so
suddenly all those old videos were in HD
and they look well it depends on the
video smash melts all-star looks awful
now there are some brilliant remasters
out there ones last Christmas is now in
4k and it looks spectacular
and that's because it was shot on film
full cinema quality the sort of thing
you can literally project on the side of
a building and it will look great same
with Freddie Mercury's living on my own
the remaster looks stunning in fact I
think that looks better because they
haven't converted to widescreen they've
kept it at the aspect ratio of old
eighties television because music videos
weren't meant for the cinema they were
meant for television it's in the name
music video so one of the first steps in
editing will have been putting the film
through a tele cine which is a very
fancy way of pointing a TV camera at a
film projector and saving the results to
video tape it is way more precise and
your average movie theater pirate with a
camcorder but the result is that all
that film quality gets crushed down onto
a standard definition TV picture stored
on magnetic tape 480 horizontal lines in
the US 576 in Europe that's it any more
quality than that is gone editing on
videotape is much cheaper and easier
than if you're putting the final version
out on television well why would you
bother with editing actual physical film
which is what you had to do back then a
few videos might have gone to that
expensive it was part of a big concert
film sake
so the Rolling Stones rock and roll
circus was played at the New York Film
Festival and you can see the Cinema
Camera with its big bulky rolls of film
in the background of some of the shots
but the final version of most music
videos will videos so for the remaster
of last Christmas a team of engineers
had to track down the original reels of
film and rescan them using modern
technology of 4k and then became staking
we took those 4k files and recreated
every edit in the original video frame
for frame cut for cut actually they were
only able to find seven of the eight
original reels of film
so there are a few shots in there where
the only source material was the TV
quality music video and you can tell
because this is what an old-school
standard-definition
analog signal looks like when you use
world-class technicians to upscale it to
4k it's not too bad I guess living on my
own also has a couple of shots where the
old 80's digital effects have been
recreated with modern tech and they're
not a perfect match and they're also a
couple of shots that have been replaced
or the timing slightly change no idea
why but again it's not a bad job now
there is a cheaper remastering option
that doesn't involve recreating the
whole edit from scratch you can take the
final TV edit from the best cleanest
professional grade videotape you can
find and upscale that to HD a lot of
remastered videos have done this it
won't be as sharp as the original film
but it will look better than people are
used to which is what they've done with
the remastered version of Bohemian
Rhapsody and look I can see why record
companies would want an HD version of
Bohemian Rhapsody its iconic it has over
a billion views on YouTube but this was
not shot on film it was recorded on TV
cameras edited on videotape you can tell
by the look at the lighting and by the
fact that these effects required live
feedback to the camera you could only
get this by pointing a television camera
directly at a monitor which means there
was never any high quality film version
this was only ever in standard
definition and remember old school
analog television in Europe runs at 50
frames a second 60 in the US but 50 in
Europe half of the horizontal lines get
skipped each time which is called
interlacing and it means you get less
flickering on old equipment so if you
want the authentic original experience
as seen back in the 70s
then Bohemian Rhapsody should be played
at standard definition at 50 interlaced
frames a second that's what was recorded
instead what you see on YouTube is a
computer's best effort to make a
high-definition 25 frames a second to
film like the picture from that limited
data filling in the gaps turning jagged
edges into smooth lines
that's called deinterlacing and it's not
done badly here remastering doesn't mean
restoration it means
Riu creation you'll see marketing blurb
saying we masters a the way it was meant
to be seen which is a great tagline but
no it wasn't remastering is to an extent
changing the historical record there are
fan remasters of Bohemian Rhapsody out
there upscaled from VHS 50 frames a
second that are much more true to the
original but at least Bohemian Rhapsody
got a decent HD remaster it's not like
what they've done to Smash Mouth look at
his face in this scene that's not a
clear high-definition picture that's
some kind of demon child it scaled up
wrongly it's it's over sharpened oh look
at the diagonal lines here they're
jagged and stepped I tracked down a
standard definition version from years
ago it's some of the uploaded and yeah I
can see why computer would do that and
oh yeah it's badly D interlaced in some
parts too because here you can see the
cheerleader is in two places at once in
the same frame it's not bleed over from
the next frame either she's in two
different places there as well saying
that this scene with the dancer what why
is there a dancer in just one scene in
this music video
but those deinterlacing artifacts I
don't understand how they're even
possible did they did they shoot some of
this on a TV camera at 60 frames a
second and then grade it to look like
film that doesn't make any sense but
that's the only way that those artifacts
could happen but other parts look fine
and look like they're on film at 30
frames a second at the part that they
pulled from the movie that it was a
tie-in to Mystery Men those run at 24
frames a second you can see in this
transition the right side is badly dear
intellect with a ghost image and and the
left side has every fifth frame doubled
so the frame rates match I genuinely
cannot understand what has happened here
it is a complete and utter mess
presumably some underpaid and overworked
VFX tech was given a low-quality already
broken copy of it and told it's just
Smash Mouth we don't care just make it
work so they threw the video into a
basic resizer to make it HD massively
dialed up the sharpness and tried to
squeeze the aspect ratio into whatever
this is the HD remaster looks worse than
the one it replaced it's sharper sure
it's not better and if you are going to
change the historical record
it does seem a terrible option
to make it worse I've got an original
series over on nebula here's the trailer
I invited five people to play some games
I trust no one none of us had
trustworthy in an environment designed
to slowly break their team apart this is
real money but all they knew is they'd
be sat around the table trying to win
real cash $10,000 the vibes changed
after that fact this is a show about
trust about loyalty and about money Tom
wants the chaos nebula is a home for new
in-depth and experimental content and
collaborations from education video
creators that you may well have heard of
and it's bundled free at this link where
the curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service with thousands of
big-budget professional documentaries
and nonfiction titles curiosity stream
is 2099 a month or only $19.99 a year
you can get a 30 day free trial
including access to nebula and my series
by going to curiosity stream comm slash
Tom Scott
you